hi
how are you good good to see you it's
good to see you too
um especially for this one which i
absolutely adored but
before i even get into kajillionaire
i've gotten into the habit
of looking back on first features and
the impressions that they might make so
maybe not your first first feature but i
adore practical magic so much
is there anything about having worked on
that set
way back when that you still find
yourself referring back to today
we just had no idea that was going to
become like the cult thing that
that it's become it's like a halloween
staple
now and i feel so happy that i i'm in
one of those
um that was really the first like big
studio film i ever did i think was the
first time i was like on a giant
sound stage doing stuff with
like huge celebrity was like sandra
bullock and nicole kidman and like
stalker channing and diane wiese
honestly i but i geeked out the most
about stalker channing and diane wiest
i honestly i mean so being able to be
there with them and watch them work and
seeing how warm and lovely and beautiful
just they were as people
that still stays with me i am i'll never
let griffin done
live down the fact that he cut out um
an entire flying scene you know when
they jump off the river then there was a
whole scene where we were flying
like before landing all that's gone we
did wire work
for like a week that just disappeared
completely
i want to see it sorry i feel like that
belongs on you know like an anniversary
dvd or something
i i i hope so man i mean the wire work
was fun it's just no one ever saw it
one can hope so with uh
with kajillionaire i was wondering do
you remember how
old olio's posture and voice were
described in the script and
how did that evolve as you kind of got
into the character
they weren't described all that much it
really came later when
the honestly the second i signed on
miranda and i started working on aldolio
because the film happened quite quickly
um
and so she would send me videos um
to study i mean right down to how i
would put my hair behind my ears we were
discussing and i would practice over and
over in front of her until
we'd get it right and then um we had to
we wanted her to be genderless you know
and so there were certain tells
of mine that may be too feminine or to
this or that that we had to eliminate
like my hands and like my voice and my
posture
um and then we would do exercises where
she would say
she'd have me improvise the scene and it
would be okay do this seem like a proud
lion
you do this scene don't look at anybody
in the eye okay do this scene and you're
not allowed to speak
um because we wanted her to have a very
animalistic primal
almost creature-like nature about her so
there are
things um that you you could
pick up in the film and go oh yeah that
is slightly animal
like when she's dancing or you know
things like that
um so we yeah we work um
intensely on it what about the decision
to kind of have a
call back to in the dance to how
she goes into the post office at the
very beginning was that yeah was that
plan that was discussed because
we thought the dancing was something we
worked on a lot because we thought
what does it look like somebody that has
had no exposure to dancing has never
really danced
what does it look like when someone
tries that on for the first time and all
she has to draw from
is the con and so we wanted it to start
with that and
those moves morph into a sort of dance
and we just thought how is this going to
work so we worked on that a lot as well
and again um i think you'll see in
in that scene um pawing again
animal-like she's like pawn she's like
trying to break
free she's been oppressed you know this
is when she explodes out of herself
and gina really started crying the first
time we did it
um she she was so moved by it because we
shot it towards the end of shooting and
and by the time we got there and we had
seen this journey that this character
got on
it was quite moving to to film that and
to watch her finally get to be free
can you tell me a little bit about
working with gene i actually i posed
this question to her also and i i just
get the feeling like you guys had a very
special collaboration
just as far as her being a scene partner
and what that
brings out in you that you know maybe
you don't have that exact same thing
with other co-stars
yeah she has a fantastic energy and we
we hit it off right away
she's so easy to fall in love with she's
such an open
giving um self-possessed fiercely
intelligent
woman um who's also hilarious
and just fun to be around um and
and i respect the hell out of her and i
and i think um
i'm very excited for people to see her
in this and see the side of her because
she's such a
tremendous actress and a very giving
scene partner
um so i really can't say enough good
things about her i adore her
yeah i can totally tell she is yeah
lovely
um what about the prep you did did you
do any kind of research into
small cons because even right at the
beginning of the movie the whole post
office thing kind of blew my mind and i
can't believe i don't hear about
people sticking their arms through p.o
boxes more often i know
i know miranda and i discussed it a lot
um
we talked about maybe pulling some
actual cons
before shooting but we didn't get a
chance but me and richard and debra
actually rehearsed a lot with miranda
and she would choreograph things for us
to do um she'd have us
change costume in the middle of the
scene she'd have us
uh steal watches and like she had us do
strange choreographed cons
um to rehearse um so that we could get
into it yeah it was uh
it was funny it was really funny i feel
like you could can you probably like
pickpocket someone now or something like
that
i don't know i no i
here's the thing the dimes are not good
con artists so
i don't know if we actually gained any
useful skills
um and i'm also a bad liar you know a
good actor is very different than a liar
and it's it's two different things so i
have that same problem i guess it's for
the better though
it is i think yeah the obligatory
westworld question for you
yes i know with some shows it can take a
little bit of time
to kind of get in the groove and you
find that groove
in seasons one and two and then they
kind of completely
shake up the show in season three so did
you have that period at the beginning
of the season where you felt yourself
readjusting
even to a show you knew so well
absolutely
it's not like that every season a bit
season three for sure because that was
just shooting a completely
different show um but luckily it's still
the same people
every year it's the same the same crew
that's been with us since the beginning
um and so it now we've been doing it so
long it very much is like a family
and it's still you know even though the
seasons change
it's still just as chaotic behind the
scenes and so it there's something
comforting about that
because it doesn't change um
but every season is is a reinvention and
jonah made that very clear
um from the beginning that you know
tear down the sets after every season
and start again
and and it's bittersweet because you get
to know these characters really well and
you like them how they are and then you
have to kind of start over every season
but i think it's what keeps it
interesting
that's what makes me excited for future
seasons so yeah what's season four going
to be
even i don't know
right now yeah no one's gonna forget but
also huge congratulations on this
i really i really really love this one
it's a it's a special one and
i wouldn't expect any less from you guys
miranda so huge congratulations
thank you so much i feel the same way